you
hey tomorrow how's it going still suck
it over watch anyway it's been a slow
start to the year for major game
releases the weeks haven't been Baron
exactly
but what juggernauts we were
anticipating have since gone down delay
avenue driving into the sunset while
most people turn to other sources of
entertainment on this lonely street
corner called February but you and me
two more
we're not like most people in an effort
to murder some time before those two
games about demonic hell escapes release
on March 20th we both chose to play an
older title a seven-year old title I'm
talking of course about Arkham origins
[Music]
rumors have hung like a fog over WB
Montreal's next project for a while now
many of them were confirmed when the
studio strongly implied that yes it's
working on another Batman game and yes
it will focus on our boys fight against
the elusive and powerful court of owls
we can get into more specifics on that
later but suffice to say what with it
being the studio's only full Batman game
to date Arkham origins is relevant once
again
so let me tea you up here before
returning to origins i remembered as the
well the hardest batman game to remember
i played through it during its 2013
release and like a great many people
felt it was a fine but forgettable game
chiefly i didn't remember it doing much
to improve upon the strong foundation
Rocksteady had laid with Arkham Asylum
and Arkham City so let me ask you how
did you remember the game before
returning to it and more importantly
what do you think of Arkham origins now
hey Mike it's gone well thanks he's
still trying to make it as a warframe
influencer anyways I think you've nailed
it by calling Arkham origins the hardest
Batman game to remember there it very
much is there in a lot of respects which
is unsurprising given how closest up to
what Rocksteady set out in their games
but it's also a game with a lot of
interesting ideas of its own and some
really memorable moments I remember
Arkham origins as a game that won me
over despite my cynicism going in I came
away from it having enjoyed the
experience as a whole and actually
impressed with some of the things that
WB Montreal did it's definitely not the
best of the bunch but I think it doesn't
deserve to be shunned at all I think
that Arkham origins realizes some of the
aspects of the become the Batman mantra
that Rocksteady didn't do much or as
well the detective part of being Batman
is kind of thin in Asylum city and even
night those games are superb and I
really adore them and they shine in so
many other ways but that's the one
element they skimp on origins went the
other way it made the whole crime scene
investigation a core part of the game
the other thing that I really like about
origins and something that it does much
better than Rocksteady's games is the
sense of time it had Rocksteady pretty
much nailed a sense of place with their
version of Gotham which is what WB
Montreal used in large part for their
game but
motley Montreal put a spin on it by
setting it during Christmas I really
respect the decision to do that as it's
also evocative of some of the most
beloved Batman stories out there stuff
like long Halloween which is also set
during Christmas and year one which is
an early career story there's so much
more to unpack about arkham origins and
it has a lot that WB montreal i think
will build on in the next project which
I also have some theories on but yeah
for now suffice it to say that I'm quite
fond of Arkham origins too late
okay as you said there's a lot to unpack
here I do agree that WB Montreal nailed
a sense of time here the Christmas trees
garlands and occasional Santa hat offer
a nice juxtaposition for Gotham's grimy
streets as well as the generally
monochromatic look of this particular
game world I also love origins focus on
crime scenes reconstructing the ordeal
using Batman's state of the art gadgets
has a voyeuristic appeal that stands out
from the combat stealth combat stealth
rhythm this series is known for the
detective scenes feel like bite-sized
bits of environmental storytelling which
when combined with the world's holiday
vibes work wonders in setting origins
apart from Rocksteady's environments
lastly I genuinely enjoy how on the nose
the whole script is in regards to
origins boss fights hey Batman here are
eight assassins you'll be fighting each
of them periodically and most of them
will drop a cool new gadget like the
Megaman boss they are have fun beating
the [ __ ] out of them sure some of these
bosses are glorified QuickTime events
I'm looking at you Deathstroke but
they're so stylish it's hard to care
with all that being said I still don't
like origins in fact I think I like it
less than I did in 2013 as much as I
wanted to enjoy this sojourn origins
reminded me why I found it forgettable
to begin with its world nails and
aesthetic yes but it's empty and vapid
it's comments tell shine early on but
they don't really evolve in any
compelling way as the hours roll by and
while I stand by what I said about the
stories decided cheesiness being a
strong point
I do wish WB Montreal did more with this
younger angrier Bruce Wayne they had at
their disposal for all of origins faults
though I am excited for the studio's
upcoming Batman game I finally read
Scott Snyder and Greg Coppola's court of
owls comic book run about a vicious
Gotham Illuminati employing dangerous
assassins known as talons to eliminate
public officials I think you'll agree
there is a lot of material to work with
here as a much more learn at Batman
aficionado than myself what do you think
WB Montreal could do with this next
adventure that's an interesting
perspective and I certainly respect your
right to incorrect opinions but before I
move on I want to call out that there
are a couple of core narrative ideas
that I really enjoyed in origin
the black mask reveal being one of them
as well as the closer inspection of the
relationship between Alfred and Bruce I
really also like that the
electrocutioner gets treated like an
absolute bottom-of-the-barrel chump
villain because he totally is looking
forward I think people are expecting
something close to what already exists
from WB Montreal given that origins was
a spin on city I think that team might
surprise us though with something that's
quite different and also much bigger in
scale than we probably expect that game
whatever it turns out to be has been in
development for a long time and I reckon
we'll get something ambitious out of
that based on the teasers it seems like
it's going to be more than just a story
about the core of the house versus
Batman I feel like the court of owls Ark
will be a huge inspiration on the game
but instead of just using a single
secret society to undermine Batman's
understanding of his home it will be
multiple large-scale threats we've also
spent so much time in Arkham City and
Gotham sea so I think now is the right
time to expand beyond it I definitely
feel like Gotham will be thereby suspect
and I hope that we'll be paying a trip
to blüdhaven at the very least and maybe
even a few places outside of that -
that'll be a great way to get some
visual variety and of course let other
members of the Bat family step into the
spotlight there's been so much work done
in making characters like Nightwing and
Batgirl interesting and playable so I
think that Montreal will take some of
that and expand upon it imagine all
those smaller DLC expansions for
previous games but instead as chapters
in a much bigger story each member of
the bat family dealing with an uprising
in a different corner of a bigger world
before coming together to take on the
masterminds the court of owls maybe
that's just a pipe dream though either
way I think for me Arkham origins left
me feeling good about what WB Montreal
could do with that universe if given the
freedom to follow their own ideas
whatever it does turn out to be I am
very very excited to see it
you
you